sorry hi everybody your next comic
coming to the stage are you guys ready
you don't number it we'll do it anyway
thanks gentlemen give it up it was very
funny huh yeah
is that for me yeah I'm Asian
just in case you can't see me back there
it's not being Asian because I feel like
I'm always representing Asia no matter
where I go like I'll be in a rush
I don't park my car quickly I'll go
inside do my business I come out I'm a
card log crooked on the wine and like oh
man now representing the college I know
why four vodkas a damn I knew it with an
Asian guy let's being Asian man this
with 10 I'm Japanese
don't be like Japanese that's like us
what the good can build a bunch of
Chinese people to Chinese people don't
like them either
yeah that's a true fact that's called
The Rape of Nanking look it up
our political commentary started comedy
watching Renee Zellweger in a Bridget
Jones diary I don't know if she the bad
actor she has weird facial expressions
and I think maybe she just looked all
squished up which gets added for most of
the movie she sat in the bathroom trying
to get laid so funny - for her
oh sorry yeah it's over so anyone here's
circumcised besides nobody active is
part of the decision-making process for
that but I don't know they just really
let's cut it off I don't like it looks
weird they don't think that the other
body part still trim your ears off if
it's too big okay the penis is important
enough they need to chop it off I just
think it's weird that way society
decided to chop off everyone's dick so I
was watching dumb does that mean I've
got it is I mean it's a minute wondering
oh you guys just making sure I'm sure
there's a Podrick so I we've got a dog
and it's kind of weird kids I like my
dog and I was like masturbating but I
can't really masturbate in front of my
dog that's kind of weird because so I
stood him out and that is a sad process
we go through mustache